IMPORTANT THERE.
>> Bret: IF THEY QUACKED, LET
US KNOW.
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN PRESIDENT
FOR ALMOST A HUNDRED DAYS.
HE'S BEEN PRESIDENT FOR 800 DAYS
PAID 675 OF THOSE INCLUDED
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION AS MOLLIE POINTED
OUT.
THERE WERE STORIES AND
ALLEGATIONS PRIOR TO THAT ABOUT
THIS RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
NO MATTER HOW YOU LOOK AT IT,
THIS IS A CONSEQUENTIAL MOMENT
FOR THIS PRESIDENCY, FOR THIS
NATION.
AND THE MATTER WHAT HAPPENS FROM
THIS REPORT, AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO POINT OUT THAT WE DON'T KNOW
THE DETAILS INSIDE BUT WE DO
KNOW FROM SENIOR DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS NOT RECOMMENDING ANY
INDICTMENTS TIED TO THIS REPORT.
JOINING US AGAIN, DANA PERINO,
ONE WILLIAMS, CHRIS WALLACE.
CHRIS?
>> WE DON'T WANT TO RUSH TO
JUDGMENT AND I THINK BECAUSE
THIS REPORT HAS COME OUT, SINCE
NO ONE HAS SEEN IT, THAT SOMEHOW
THIS CLEARS THE PRESIDENT, SEEMS
LIKE THE HEIGHT OF RUSHING TO
JUDGMENT.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE
APPOINTMENT OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THE FACT IS THE REASON THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL WAS APPOINTED,
THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT
FIRED JAMES COMEY, >> Bret:
8 WAS ALLOWED TO FINISH HIS
INVESTIGATION, THERE WOULD BE NO
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
I'M SURPRISED ABOUT THE TALK OF
PROCESS CRIMES.
PROCESS CRIMES ARE NOT PARKING
TICKETS.
PROCESS CRIMES ARE LYING TO
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS, THIS IS THE
VERY BASIS OF WHICH JUSTICE IS
ADMINISTERED TO THE DEGREE THAT
YOU COMMIT PERJURY, THAT'S A
VERY SERIOUS CRIME, BUT THEY
WILL HIDE IMPORTANT FACTS,
INVESTIGATORS WANT TO KNOW.
WE SHOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR, THE
SPECIAL COUNSELOR RESULTED IN
THE INDICTMENT AND GUILTY PLEAS
AND SERIOUS AND CONVICTIONS OF
MICHAEL FLYNN, THE FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR TO THE
PRESIDENT, PAUL MANAFORT, THE
FORMER CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN FOR THE
PRESIDENT FOR SEVERAL MONTHS,
AND MICHAEL COHEN, THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL LAWYER AND
FIXER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS IN KIND OF
A BIG PICTURE WAY, THERE'S NO
QUESTION THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
UNDER A CLOUD FOR HIS ENTIRE
PRESIDENCY ON THE QUESTION OF
THIS INVESTIGATIONS SUSPICIONS
AND A FORMAL INVESTIGATION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT HE COLLUDED WITH
THE RUSSIANS AND WHETHER HE
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
THE FACT THAT THAT INVESTIGATION
IS OVER IS A BIG MILESTONE EVEN
IF WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT THE FINAL
CONCLUSION OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL WAS.
WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE,
AND I DO THINK THAT IF, AND
REPEAT IT, IT SHOULD BE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS CLEARED OF THE
BASIC FUNDAMENTAL CHARGES OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, WHETHER IT WAS
ONE COLLUSION OR TWO OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE, THAT IS A MAJOR
VICTORY FOR THE PRESIDENT.
YES, CONGRESS AND THE SIX
COMMITTEES WILL CONTINUE TO
INVESTIGATE.
BUT IF HE'S BASICALLY CLEARED OF
THOSE CHARGES, THEN IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
RELATIVELY LITTLE PATIENCE ON
THE PART OF THE PUBLIC FOR A
CONTINUING INVESTIGATION AND
THEY'LL BE SEEN SIMPLY BY AN
EFFORT BY DEMOCRATS TO TRY AND
FIND WAYS TO CUT UP THE
PRESIDENT AFTER THE ELECTION.
BUT ON THE BASIC CHARGE, THE
CLOUD HE'S BEEN UNDER, IF THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT, IT'LL BE A
TREMENDOUS VICTORY FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND HE'LL BE LARGELY
IN THE CLEAR IN TERMS OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> Bret: TO YOU, DANA, WE ARE
MAKING CLEAR THIS IS A
CONSEQUENTIAL MOMENT.
THE BIG MOMENT NO MATTER WHAT'S
IN THE REPORT AND THE CAVEATS
ALL OVER THE PLACE, THE POLITICS
ARE FRONT AND CENTER.
>> ONE THING THAT COULD BE VERY
INTERESTING IS BECAUSE THIS HAS
BEEN SO SECRETIVE IN MANY WAYS,
YOU THINK ABOUT ROBERT MUELLER,
THERE HAVE BEEN NO LEAKS, NO
GRANDSTANDING, HE'S RUN A VERY
TIGHT SHIP AND THAT'S A GOOD
EXAMPLE ON HOW TO KEEP THE
INTEGRITY OF AN INVESTIGATION,
AND I THINK HE ENDS THIS WITH
HIS REPUTATION THAT WAS ALREADY
STELLAR, HE LEAVES WITH THAT
COMPLETELY INTACT, AND NOW HE
CAN GO BACK TO DOING WHATEVER HE
WAS TRYING TO DO BEFORE HE WAS
CALLED BACK INTO SERVICE TO DO
THIS REPORT.
IN ADDITION THOUGH, BRET, THINK
ABOUT ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE HAD TO HIRE LAWYERS, HAD TO
BE INTERVIEWED BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
IT IS VERY STRESSFUL.
IT'S SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO KEEP
VERY QUIET, BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR
ATTORNEY AND YOUR FAMILY, THAT'S
IT.
WE MIGHT START TO HEAR A LITTLE
MORE ABOUT THAT.
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT WE'LL LEARN
WITH THE EXTENT OF IT, BUT OF
COURSE WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT HAD TO SUBMIT TO THOSE
INTERVIEWS SO WE MIGHT HEAR A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THEY WERE
TREATED AND -- HOWEVER, THAT
SAID, WHEN YOU ASK ABOUT THE
POLITICS, I THINK THERE WILL BE
AS CHRIS SAID VERY LITTLE
PATIENCE AND CONGRESS DECIDE
THAT THEY WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
JUST GO BACK OVER THIS ENTIRE
REPORT.
YOU JUST SAID IT WAS A TWO-YEAR
REPORT?
$12 MILLION, $25 MILLION TOTAL?
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YES, THEY
WANT TO KNOW WHAT WAS IN IT,
THEY WANT TO SEE THE DEMOCRATS
REHASH THIS FOR HER TO GO MORE
YEARS?
THE DEMOCRATS, DO THEY WANT TO
SHOW THAT THEY CAN GOVERN, DO
THEY WANT TO GO BACK ON ISSUES
THAT MATTER?
2020 IS REALLY NOT THAT FAR AWA
AWAY.
>> Bret: ONE THING TO POINT
OUT BEFORE I GET TO YOU, ONE,
NOT ONE PERSON IS GETTING
INDICTED IN CONSPIRING WITH
RUSSIA, AND THAT'S A FACT FROM
OFFICIALS FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, REPORT OR NO REPORT
AS WE LEARNED WHATEVER'S IN IT.
SOME EXPERTS WHO KNOW THIS VERY
WELL SAY THIS.
THERE COULD BE A SECRET GRAND
JURY, INFORMATION KNOWN AS SIX
CE, THAT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
RELEASED PUBLICLY SINCE
WITNESSES DO NOT HAVE LAWYERS
PRESENCE IN THOSE GRAND JURY
PROCEEDINGS, AND IT'S NOT
TECHNICALLY A COURT PROCEEDING
FOR THERE COULD BE SECRET
INTELLIGENT INFORMATION IN THE
REPORT, WHICH COULD DAMAGE
NATIONAL SECURITY IN SOME WAY,
SHAPE, OR FORM FOR THERE COULD
BE UNPROVEN OR PROVOCATIVE
STATEMENTS OR CLAIMS IN THE
REPORT, BUT TESTED BY A COURT
PROCESS THAT ARE OVER THE TOP.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS NOT JUST
A CLERK IN THIS PROCESS, HE HAS
SIGNIFICANT CONSTITUTIONAL AND
STATUTORY ROLE, SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER REPORTS TO HIM.
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
EXERCISING HIS JUDGMENT IN THIS
CASE.
JUST ADDING THAT TO THIS
CONVERSATION.
>> THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT.
YOU GOT TO GET IN
YOU KEEP IN MIND AFTER A
TWO-YEAR LONG PROCESS WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM ROBERT MUELLER ON
THE RECORD, IF YOU WILL, WHAT'S
IN THE PUBLIC AT THIS MOMENT IS
THAT HE HAS CHARGED 34 PEOPLE
WITH CRIMES, BRET, SIX PEOPLE
WHO WERE INTIMATE WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
MIKE FLYNN, FOR EXAMPLE, PAUL
MANAFORT.
APPARENTLY MANAFORT WAS
PROVIDING POLLING INFORMATION.
ALL OF THIS IS KNOWN BECAUSE OF
THE INDICTMENTS THAT WERE FILED
BY ROBERT MUELLER.
IN ADDITION, YOU HAVE 24 PEOPLE
OF THE 34 IN TOTAL THAT HAVE
BEEN CHARGED WITH CRIMES WHO ARE
RUSSIANS, WHO IN FACT ARE
RUSSIANS THAT HE HAS CHARGED
WITH INTERFERING IN THE 2016
ELECTION.
WE WILL NEVER SEE THOSE PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT BE
EXTRADITED FROM RUSSIA TO COME
AND FACE A TRIAL HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
SO THAT, IN A SENSE, GIVES YOU
THE UNIVERSE THAT IS ON THE
RECORD OF WHAT WE KNOW FROM
MUELLER'S WORK.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE POLITICS OF
IT, YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ALREADY CHOMPING
AT THE BIT TO SAY WHY DIDN'T
MUELLER GO FURTHER, SPECIFICALLY
IN REGARDS TO MUELLER
TRUMP'S RELATIONSHIPS TO SOME OF
THE OLIGARCHS, DEUTSCHE BANK
SPECIFICALLY HAS COME TO GREAT
ATTENTION IN RECENT DAYS, LOANS
MADE TO, ALLEGED LIES TOLD IN
TERMS OF TRUMP'S WEALTH.
MUCH OF THIS LAID OUT BY ANOTHER
TRUMP INTIMATE MICHAEL COHEN
WHEN HE WAS BROUGHT BEFORE
CONGRESS AND TESTIFIED AND SAID
THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE IN THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION WHO KNEW
ABOUT THESE THINGS.
THAT IS THE KIND OF LINE OF
BREADCRUMBS THAT LEADS TO SO
MUCH OF THE ACTIVITY THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE PLACE IN THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT PROSECUTORS
OFFICE HERE IN NEW YORK, BUT
ALSO GIVE AMMUNITION TO
DEMOCRATS WHO ALREADY, IT SEEMS
TO ME, READYING FOR THE 2020
CAMPAIGN SAYING, WE WANT TO KNOW
MORE AND WE ARE WILLING TO PUT
MORE OUT THERE ON THE RECORD TO
KEEP THIS FLAME GOING AS WE
BEGIN THE POLITICAL PROCESS FOR
THE 2020 ELECTION.
>> Bret: CHRIS, TO MARK THIS
MOMENT, MARCH 22ND 2019 TURNS
OUT THE DATE THAT'LL GO UNDER
THE HISTORY BOOKS.
JUST NOTING THAT THE REPORT IS
IN.
TWO
TO JUAN'S POINT, NOT
UNDERSTANDING ALL THAT'S UNDER
THIS REPORT, BUT IF THE
PRESIDENT IS LARGELY CLEARED IN
THE REPORT AND USING IT TO SAY,
SEE, I TOLD YOU SO, IS THERE A
DECISION FOR DEMOCRATS TO MAKE
ON THE INVESTIGATIONS THAT THEY
HAVE LAUNCHED ALREADY AS WE HEAD
INTO THIS NEXT ELECTION THAT, AS
GOVERNOR RENDELL TOLD US ON
ELECTION NIGHT IN MIDTERMS, YOU
HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
LEGISLATE, LEGISLATE, LEGISLATE,
OR INVESTIGATE, INVESTIGATE,
INVESTIGATE?
>> IT GETS VERY HARD.
TAKE FOR INSTANCE THE WEEK THAT
MICHAEL COHEN TESTIFIED, WE
FORGET IF IT'S THE GUN REFORM
BILL, OR THE ELECTION REFORM
BILL, BUT THE FACT THAT THE
COHEN HEARINGS SUCKED UP THE OX
AGAIN.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE
TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT THIS.
WE ARE ALL TIRED OF THIS
INVESTIGATION AND IT'S BEEN A
STRAIN ON THE PRESIDENT
ESPECIALLY ON PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HAD TO HIRE LAWYERS, I KNOW WHAT
I LAWYERS HOURLY FEE IN D.C. IS,
SUBSTANTIAL.
BUT THE COUNTRY AT LARGE IS
SUFFERING MUELLER FATIGUE.
THE BOTTOM LINE, AND IF THE
BOTTOM LINE HAS BEEN CLEARED OF
THE MAJOR CHARGES, OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE, COLLUSION, A LOT
MORE HOPE
HIGH-PROFILE HEARINGS, THEY WILL
PURSUE FOR A WHILE, ENERGIZES
THEIR BAYS, THERE WILL BE A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THE COUNTRY
THAT REGARDLESS OF WHAT IS
SHOWN HERE IS GOING TO OPPOSE
THE PRESIDENT AND WANT TO SEE
HIM BROUGHT DOWN, WHETHER IN THE
ELECTION OR IMPEACHMENT.
BUT I DO THINK THERE IS A DANGER
FOR DEMOCRATS IF THEY CONTINUE
TO PURSUE THIS TOO ALONG THE IT
SUCKS UP THE OXYGEN, AND IF THEY
ARE LEGISLATING, PEOPLE WON'T BE
PAYING ATTENTION TO THAT.
THEY WILL THINK THAT THESE, THE
HOUSE DEMOCRATS, THAT'S THE
CHAMBER BECAUSE THEY CONTROL
THAT THE CHAMBER, THAT THEY ARE
JUST DUTY-BOUND AND DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO CARVE OUT
THE DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, I THINK THAT
WILL BE VERY TRICKY FOR THEM AS
TO HOW FAR THEY GO ON THAT.
>> Bret: DANA, IT'S WORTH
POINTING OUT THAT YOU HAD JOHN
BRENNAN, THE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR
ON ANOTHER CHANNEL PREDICTING
JUST RECENTLY THAT WHEN THE
MUELLER REPORT COMES DOWN THAT
THERE WILL BE MULTIPLE
INDICTMENTS OF PEOPLE VERY
FAMILIAR, SIGNIFICANT NAMES,
QUITE FAMILIAR TO THE AVERAGE
AMERICANS, GOING TO THE TOP,
PREDICTING THAT THIS WOULD BE
ALL WRAPPED UP IN A RUSH OF
CONSPIRACY COLLUSION AND
INDICTMENTS FROM THIS REPORT.
THAT, EVEN THOUGH WE DO NOT KNOW
THE REPORT, WE KNOW THAT IS NOT
TRUE.
>> HE MIGHT HAVE EGG ON HIS
FACE, RIGHT?
OF COURSE, PARTISANS MIGHT SAY
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME.
HOWEVER THERE WERE THESE --
THERE IS THE POSSIBILITY OF
SEALED INDICTMENTS.
THAT MIGHT MEAN THERE ARE NO
MORE INDICTMENTS COMING, BUT
THEY WERE SEALED INDICTMENTS,
PERHAPS THOSE AREN'T GOING TO GO
ANYWHERE.
SPEWING TANGENTIAL TO RUSSIA?
>> IF THEY ARE SEALED, DO WE
KNOW THAT, BRET?
>> Bret: THEY COULD BE.
THERE ARE NO INDICTMENTS TIED TO
THIS REPORTS ON SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER'S RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
>> MAY BE THOSE SEALED
INDICTMENTS, MAYBE WE'LL NEVER
KNOW.
THE OTHER THING, THIS REPORT
COULD TAKE TIME TO PARSE OUT, I
DO THINK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILL MAKE A GOOD ON HIS CLAIM
THAT THIS WEEKEND HE'LL BE ABLE
TO RELEASE SOMETHING TO THE
PEOPLE AND THERE IS PENT-UP
DEMAND FOR IT.
I THINK HE'LL BE ABLE TO DO
THAT.
BUT AS YOU KNOW, BRET BAIER DOWN
THAT, IT'S NOT GOING TO SATISFY,
LOOKING AT THE 2020 DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES, ALL DEMANDING THAT T
CANDIDATES, ALL DEMANDING THAT I
CANDIDATES, ALL DEMANDING THAT S
REPORT BE RELEASED, THEY WANTED
IN FULL TO IT ONE OF THE THINGS
I HAVE TO ASK THEM THOUGH, LET'S
SAY THE PRESIDENT IS TOTALLY
EXONERATED.
LET'S SAY THAT MUELLER FOUND
THAT YES, RUSSIA WAS TRYING TO
INTERFERE IN OUR ELECTION, BUT
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WASN'T DOING
ANYTHING.
WOULDN'T THAT ACTUALLY BE GOOD
NEWS FOR THE COUNTRY ARE QUICK
TO MAKE SETTING ASIDE THE
POLITICS, THEY AREN'T
NECESSARILY GOING TO WIN ON THIS
POLITICALLY DIPLOMA BUT
WOULDN'T THAT BE A GREAT THING,
IF WE FIND OUT THERE WAS NO
PROBLEM?
GOOD, HOW DO WE GET TO THE
BUSINESS OF PREVENTING RUSSIA
FROM INTERFERING IN THE FUTURE?
>> Bret: JUAN, FINAL WORD
HERE.
NOTICING THE TIME HERE, FRIDAY
AFTERNOON.
USUALLY FRIDAY LATE AFTERNOON IS
WHEN BAD NEWS IS DUBBED BY
ADMINISTRATION LEFT AND RIGHT
HEADING INTO THE WEEKEND FOR
THIS FRIDAY IS EVEN MORE SO
UNDER THE RADAR.
YOU HAVE THE NCAA TOURNAMENT
PLAYING ON OTHER CHANNELS AS
TEAMS ARE FIGHTING IT OUT IN
THEIR BRACKETS.
WHAT ABOUT THE TIMING OF THIS AS
WE HEAD INTO THE WEEKEND?
IS THERE ANY THOUGHT BEHIND
THAT?
>> WELL, I DO NOT THINK ROBERT
MUELLER IS PAYING TOO MUCH
ATTENTION TO THAT.
I THINK THE PRESSURE HERE, THE
POLITICAL PRESSURE IS SO
INTENSE, THAT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE AT THE EPICENTER OF THIS, I
THINK THE EFFORT WAS TO GET IT
DONE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE,
THAT THEY DID NOT WANT THIS TO
DRAG ON.
YOU GO BACK TO THE
CLINTON-LEWINSKY AFFAIR, GO BACK
TO WHITEWATER, GO BACK TO
WATERGATE.
THESE THINGS ALL TOOK MUCH
LONGER THAN THE ALMOST TWO YEAR
PERIOD WE ARE ATTACHED TO THE
MUELLER REPORT.
I THINK FOR MUELLER, THE
EMPHASIS WAS TO DO IT QUICKLY
AND MAINTAIN CREDIBILITY.
I CAN'T EMPHASIZE -- I THINK
EVERYBODY THAT YOU TO TALK TO
HERE THIS EVENING HAS SAID THAT
ROBERT MUELLER TO THIS POINT HAS
COME OUT OF THIS WITH HIS
INTEGRITY INTACT, THAT PEOPLE
EXPECT THAT HE WOULD HAVE DONE A
THOROUGH JOB AND THE POLLS SHOW
THIS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK HE HAS
BEEN FAIR.
THE FACT THAT HE HAS BEEN
SILENT, THERE HAVE NOT BEEN
LEAKS OUT OF HIS OFFICE, HAS
HELPED TO A SORT THAT HE HAS
BEEN CONDUCTING A FAIR
INVESTIGATION, NOT USING THE
MEDIA TO HIS ADVANTAGE, HE
WANTED TO GET DONE QUICKLY SO
PEOPLE WHAT ENTIRE OF IT.
I AGREE YOU WITH THE SPECIAL
"THE SPECIAL REPORT," YOU HAVE
TO DEAL WITH LATE FRIDAY NIGHT
DUMPS.
THIS IS ABOUT SIMPLY GETTING US
TO THE POINT WHERE YOU CAN TAKE
SOME OF THE PRESSURE OFF THE
PRESIDENT, GOOD OR BAD TO COME
OR LEAVE THAT UP TO THE
PARTISANS TO THE SIDE, AND